so let's talk a little bit about the the
election I'm very excited because this
is just it's a lot of hanging meat for a
comedian you know I mean these are just
softballs there yeah and so Donald Trump
let's start with Donald Trump Donald
what do you make of this is this real is
this Donald as an old friend of mine I
tell there are two sides to Donald he's
a he's a good person he's uh he's a
great father he has very successful
businessman and if you were in trouble
you could go to him Donald has a good
heart
Donald has an incredible ego and Donald
you like Donald because there's no cut
off from breda mouth yeah it's an
interview he's a piece of cake yeah you
want him yeah so he'll be refreshing he
will tell you exactly what he however
demented someone who takes exactly what
he thinks about his fellow Republicans
yeah if I were a Republican candidate
now I would not look forward to this
because he will get attention he'll get
so a percentage of the polls he'll get
on the debates and it and then all hell
could break loose right I mean to me I
think you're totally right he's walking
out he's gonna be rapping these
opponents he's already wrapped Jeb Bush
terribly good he's gonna take them on
yeah as he called George Bush the worst
president till Obama came into be the
worst force a tie for his worse his two
ties for the worst president our
Republican and a Democrat yeah there you
go but he's I think he's delightful you
know I mean I do look at him as uh so
you're separating the he's not gonna
resident so do you but do you think he's
do is this real is he do you think he's
really running for president cuz I have
a sense that this is sort of you know
this is brand and ego and then sometime
around October after a couple debates
where I think he's gonna do well he'll
say I did it and now now the well
there's that side that says Donald could
not stand going into a primary and
losing yeah because that ego couldn't
take a defeat yeah my old friend Howard
Cosell the late Howard Cosell a strong
liberal
all of a said he's gonna run for the
Senate in New York and he but he never
was gonna run because he couldn't take
the fact that he would be voted down
yeah so maybe you're right maybe Donald
will campaign a little and get out
before the first vote saying I've made
my voice clear and I now endorse
such-and-such all right well we but I
don't think he wants to face an election
yeah
but I like Donald Trump so what do you
make of the rest of the Republicans
because there's a ton of them it's
actually you know people mock the
Republican Party for not being an open
party and all that so it's an open part
actually now you know there there is a
woman there is a black guy there's a
Hispanic guy I mean there's a lot of
white guys but if they have broadened it
I'm not enamored with any of these guys
but they've done so there are no
moderate Republicans anymore they used
to be a great crew of moderate
Republicans there are no moderate
Republicans and as very few moderate
Democrats yeah Democrats uh swinging
Elizabeth Warren seems to be the the
heart of the Democratic Party and
Hillary is moving more toward this one
so we have no centrist and when there
are no centrist that's a danger in a
republic mm-hmm because the Republic
needs compromise it needs centrist
Hillary was a centrist senator she was a
very good in fact Lindsey Graham told me
once he would be very comfortable if
Hillary Clinton ran for national office
because she could work with her right
she was in the Senate she knew how to
give and take and she could give up this
to get that that was that's very
important you have to do that yeah at
which we don't do anymore right they as
you said what McConnell said right when
Obama got elected it'll be defeat him at
every turn so we have that kind of hate
and that does leave you know I when I
was a kid first I could name every
senator I can't do that I won't make you
do it now no you don't I won't I
wouldn't be able to do it number two I
knew that that set Barry Goldwater when
John Kennedy were friends Republicans
and Democrats went out
yeah and had dinner together a
conservative Mormon and a democratic
liberal Ted Kennedy yeah D spoke at his
funeral
they this is
what America was yes so is this just
another thing danger got about it now is
because of Congress they come in on
Tuesday and leave on Friday because
they're constantly running for
reelection on its two-year thing they
don't live in Washington anymore they
take a room in Washington they run back
home to Cantor do things that are not
there Friday Saturday Sunday Monday yeah
so then is money is money in politics
only is that what every word everything
else is that were Supreme Court decision
yeah of all time was that a corporation
is a person yeah and that you can give
any kind of money to any kind of thing
in US is freedom of speech yeah that
that decision was horrendous I think so
he made a lot of horrendous decisions
they're making a bunch of decisions now
which way do you think they're gonna go
on gay marriage they could be people are
saying it could be as early as this week
I think Justice Kennedy will swing that
way I think he's always went that way
I've spent some time with him and I I
would say it's five for those swing that
maybe even six three yeah nobody wants
to be on the wrong side of history on
though they know it's happening anyway
right and on health care too
yeah if you if they if they throw out
this any major portion of health care
thing get thirteen million people are on
it yeah you know health care as a fact
and while you can look back and go what
with the concept no come on yeah we're
the only industrialized nation in the
world until Obama had this it didn't
have a health care plan and health is a
right I think it's a right